welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and if you haven't clone
problems I feel bad for your son I got
clone Force 99 and the batch ain't one
hit me
so what yeah now the fourth episode is
now out and throughout this video we're
gonna be going through the latest entry
and packing all the Easter eggs in it
and also giving our thoughts on what
they could be teasing out with Sid the
entry is called faster and this entire
episode is based around right racing
this seems like it's the more chaotic
version of pod racing which we of course
saw all the way back in The Phantom
Menace that movie spawned numerous games
including Pod racer for the N64 which I
don't mean to brag about but I was I was
basically the sebulba in my house my dad
couldn't beat me my sister no chance and
my mum she couldn't even get the engine
started what a chump see a chump and the
track itself has noticeable nods to the
one from house Eisley there's a starting
position with the upper seat that looks
similar to how it was laid out in that
film there's ramps as well and these
very much replace the sand ones that we
had on the planet the races are also
shown in the same end as the pod racing
one and we'll get into these characters
later on in the video however Journey
back to my youth with me once more and I
actually think this also takes
inspiration from another PlayStation
classic all the way back in 1997 there
was a futuristic racing game called
Wipeout 2097 and these two had tracks
like this laid out across its Universe
these were lit up with neon signs and
metallic tracks that bend around the
planets like what we have here might be
a reach might not but do me a favor and
reach for that Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy the video make sure you subscribe
for breakdowns Jango fed for a king and
with that out of the way let's get into
the bad batch
so we start off on odd mantel which is
looking a lot brighter than usual this
is one of the corners of the Galaxy that
still hasn't been overtaken by the
Empire at this point and it doesn't get
its claws into it until much later on
however I have a feeling that Sid might
even end up potentially selling out the
batch and this could be what's being
teased at I really doubt it but I think
it's a theory worth exploring as there
are several warnings of Sid's vicious
past I think most likely Hero on the
Sykes could reach out to the Imperials
and this will be how Crosshair and
Rampart end up tracking them down now we
get to the streets and see a girl
walking through eating what appears to
be a mile run fruit I think if that's
how you pronounce it now this is a snack
that's popped up throughout the Saga and
godels have also appeared throughout
several different things and since Paulo
we see a mega and wrecker playing Hollow
chess which is sure to resemble how it
played out in A New Hope now every time
we visit this bar we have to point out
that the three pumps in the back are
also what appeared in A New Hope and
these ended up being used as the head of
ig88 thumbs down on the video if you're
sick of that Easter egg but I don't know
if you've watched these videos before so
I have to keep including it and I hope
you guys forgive me you know you will
now Mega says that recarosa two cons of
mental mix and this is something that
the pair rate throughout season one at
several points looks like no one can
escape the energy crisis and even Sid is
worried about the electricity bills hey
grinding up the power bill on the ball
we can see that Tech is playing the card
game to back which is also the thing
that Han won the Millennium Falcon in
now it turns out Hunter and Echo are
transporting Nerf nuggets which are
basically what Nerf herders
you can't use that word only we can use
that word sorry N word herders make from
the bison-like creatures Nerfs now
neither of these two are in the episode
and instead we get a story focused on
these three and Sid AZ is still working
in the bar and I actually suspect that
he might be the first of crosshairs
victims when he comes to the Parlor
looking for the batch now when it comes
to Star Wars you know that lightsabers
are the coolest things in the galaxy and
that's why we've teamed up with owner
saber to bring you 20 off everything on
their site these are top of the line
replicas and you can choose from Padawan
saber's Master ones Elite ones and the
more exotic ones from the Star Wars saga
there's even a Lego one which I bloody
love it now each lightsaber comes with
an SN pixel soundboard that has 16 sets
of sound fonts you can also choose from
nine different blade colors and each one
brings with it a realistic ignition
sound and other sound effects this has
got realistic dealing sounds Blaster
blocks and full control over everything
I picked up the night Reaper and as you
can hear it's got realistic sound
effects really smooth swing Blaster
blocks yeah really cool
it also came with spare screws a wrench
manual and a little booklet detailing
everything about it it's such a cool way
to start the new year and you can buy
now and pay later with afterpay that
allows you to pay in four to six weekly
payments you will check out the deal
where you enter heavy spoilers at
checkout for 20 off don't be the Obi-Wan
to miss out on this deal owners Say by
know what they're talking about so head
over to the website now which is linked
in the description enter heavy spoilers
at checkout and get 20 off that's 20 off
on a saber by clicking the link in the
description and entering heavy spoilers
at the checkout May the force be with
you goodbye now the planet is packed
with aliens but we first start off with
a focus on a bottle I believe this is
the drink fatro which is served in
containers across the entire galaxy we
don't see who this belongs to but later
on the champion is set sibbing it so
this is probably our introduction to him
here as we pull up we see a girl again
some rodians some Twilights and some
arkonas which are those weird triangle
head aliens I will also I always forget
whether it's 3 Lex or Twilight so let me
know in the comments below but don't
spell it any differently just write the
word twelix now there's all Zona coolish
which is the same species as Ponder Baba
and all of these aliens appeared in the
most eyes of the Cantina which was the
hive of scum and villainy not being
racist mate but them appearing here
again let's just say it paints out this
area as not being the most upstanding
Place apologies if any aliens got
offended with that bit now Sid takes
them to the main Arena which we also see
using a bridge for the start and finish
line with lights in the middle like the
Pod racer track there's also a tower
where the commentators set in and I'm
pretty sure this is the first time that
Riot Racing's been in the Saga let me
know if I'm wrong though and on the
track we see pitroids along with a
racing Droid as well known as ringer
droids they're used because of their
processing power which means they can
make split-second decisions that allow
them to race at such high speeds this
was something Qui-Gon discussed in The
Phantom Menace and he said that Anakin's
reflexes would have to be similar to
were Jedis in order to be able to do
this Teo is very used to winning and as
we say pride comes before a fall I love
the way his head flips around so he can
talk to people behind him and he's got
this pretty cool design that makes him
Adept at being a writer his modified
speeder gets burst up on the cause but
first he will meet the gang stay in
greeny milegi Voice by my guy Ernie
Hudson you know he told the world that
bursting makes you feel good as a
Ghostbuster now his species is quite
rare and this is actually a doubting if
you played Fallen order then you might
recognize these species and Knight
sister is one and the same he also has a
gamorian with him and his champ who
Greenie wants to pit against SIDS and
unlike pod racing attacking the other
players is allowed in right racing when
sebulba was doing a cheering Phantom
Menace he was breaking the rules and all
this stuff with his flamethrower built
into the Pod was only overlooked because
of the gangsters on the planet that ran
the entire circuit yeah though it's
allowed and we see the first race
playing at amongst the races we can
catch a BX battle droid and you might
recognize them as appearing in the
episode last week these were highly
advanced battle droids but they were
only used in extreme circumstances
because they were more costly to produce
after the war ended many droids
continued operating but like the Clones
they had to find other roles that
weren't them being soldiers similar to
how the bad batch have gone off and done
their own thing they have two and they
very much represent the remnants of war
that no longer have a true purpose you
also see a protocol Droid and quite a
funny one that calls back to attack of
the Clones that we'll talk about in just
a bit now we see just how dangerous ride
racing is when an innocent bystander
gets hit when the guy starts throwing
shots out to everyone like when I call
my viewers Chumps in front of him as a
Beth and it goes to show Life's a bit
and then you die the writers get to a
canyon similar to Baggers and they make
a point of not taking the left tunnel
which foreshadows the events later on
now whereas jab has sat in the main
tower in Phantom Menace here we see
malagi desert in his his Champion takes
out Teo with a reverse sword with him
being bottlenecked in similar to what
happens to Tech later on Teo has been
completely bussed up and malagi comes to
collect said's been running checks at a
buck on cash unless they put it on an
All or Nothing bet this Echoes the one
in Phantom Menace that Qui-Gon had with
wodo and a ton of milagi should be
accepting all these Bets with kids who
clearly can't pay up no way she's paying
you money now milegi takes Sid and gives
them 24 hours to repair the racer they
start to fix up Teo who says incapable I
am ready to where are my arms and legs
got a lot of Vibes to C3PO panicking
when he'd been shot in Empire and as
they say it's sort of like poetry they
rhyme Tech talks about how this isn't
the first time that SIDS cause them
trouble because of her dealings and this
is likely a nod to Duran in season 1. it
had me saying Teo I'm tired of you in
technology
it's like sit in my leggy sit and drinks
at all times with a former saying that
she's changed my leggy thing Sid's true
nature will surface eventually and if
put in a precarious position she might
have to choose between herself in the
bad batch the Empire are of course going
to be hunting them and I think it's
going to be her on the line come the
latter part of the Season Tech tries to
tell Teo the best route for the cause
but he smashed like it's a like button
by a stray racer this Tech has detector
the track and were introduced to the
races this includes a battle droid head
placed on a protocol droid's body and if
you cast your mind back to attack of the
Clones then you might remember c-3pl had
something similar this was a van cheaper
back to normal but I'd like to think
that this battle droid ended up being
put back on a protocol droid's body and
this is my guy living his life in the
fast lane having survived the war anyway
the race begins with it immediately
heating up as the races fly through the
tunnels we get several ads and in the
back we can see a yellow serif class
Urban Land speeder one these were shown
on Naboo in the Phantom Menace and you
could play one in battle for Naboo on
the N64 and how I miss those days now
there's also one for chorusan before we
go to pitroids giving the hat-trick a
phantom menace Easter eggs Tech ends up
ditching weapons on the speeder so that
he can go faster and he also puts
further energy into his shield so that
he can survive the blasts slowly he
makes his way up the chain as the races
are whittled down and he takes the left
offshoot tunnel this is pretty much the
Temple of Doom track filled with
precarious holes and death-defying drops
however it gives Tech a boost and when
he's bottlenecked in like how Tayo was
he manages to emerge it on top this is
through using the two races against each
other and these were clearly part of the
bad and malagi's crew however it's
backfired and inso Boba style are taken
out before hitting the finish line and
the batch gotta gets it back the
gangster stops his champion from
shooting them and instead he gives a
warning that Sid can't be trusted we
don't really know much about her and
again I feel like she may be the
linchpin that brings everything with
them Crashing Down down anyway that ends
the entry and I thought this was a fun
episode that reminded me why this is pod
race well right racing but this is POD
racing anyway it was nice just having an
offshoot with some of the batch and
though it didn't push the overall story
forward massively it's hard to ding this
episode because of how fun it was
overall so yeah really enjoyed it and
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it
below we are running a competition right
now giving away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at Hobby spoilers you on smells
to watch them make sure you check out
our Brighton of The Last of Us which
will be linked on screen right now it's
so in depth really proud of ourselves
wow shout out to myself for how how deep
I go on that and yeah definitely check
it out right after this by the way
thanks for searching the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace